foreign
[Music]
ER video Let's do one on centrifuges
okay led me some centrifuges all right
um now is this the one where you sit in
a chair and go around or the one where
you mix up separate your blood in a
little it includes all of the above
it includes all of the above so
uh do you realize that if you have a
some solution liquid solution in a
bottle and just set it out on the table
and then something settle to the bottom
and other things in the middle and Rise
To The Top
that is kind of like a centrifuge
a little bit I guess
okay
because the boring centrifuges it is
because the denser things go to the
bottom because you had shaken it up and
everything sort of flow everything it's
mixed in with itself and you give it a
chance the dense things sink we it's
colloquially called The heavier things
sink but specifically it's the denser
things that's it's not how much it
weighs it's how dense it is right okay a
log is very heavy you throw it into a
pool it floats right okay so weight is
not what matters here it's density okay
by the way your neighbor will be very
upset and parents you have to come get
that thing out and man is that tough
so by the way logs don't float very high
on the water surface like you know
most of it is below the water and so
it's not like Styrofoam where you know
most of it is above the water right so
depending on how dense it is uh relative
to water determines where it uh where it
will float but its floating level is but
it has to be sort of totally less dense
than water but how less dense are you is
what it comes down to and styrofoam is
really less dense anyway that
that's neither here nor there actually
it actually is there but it's not here
so so here's a bottle on your shelf
that's that's a passive centrifuge
that is a 1G centrifuge uh-huh think
about it that way gotcha you're sitting
here in Earth's gravity all right and in
Earth's gravity which is 1g it will
settle things out at the rate that you
see
okay so now how do I create artificial
gravity well we do it in space well we
CA science fiction does it in space
correctly all the time what do they do
they make the space station spin see so
you spin it up and if you spin you
create like this centrifugal force that
you feel as you're out on the rim
and that's basically a centrifuge
all right so you can calculate what
speed you'd have to rotate it to field
1G
right and if you do that and you take
out your bottle that's a 1G centrifuge
that's what you're experiencing sitting
here on Earth one with a bottle on your
table okay okay so now
let's rotate you
faster
okay
well the centrifugal force increases
and the urge for the stuff in your
liquid to separate becomes enhanced
okay
the denser stuff wants to get to the
bottom faster
of course and the bottom means the side
that's away from the radius from the
center of the rotation okay so the
faster you do this the better the
separation is of anything that finds
itself at different various densities
hmm
so that's what centrifuges are and
that's how they work and if you have a
tabletop centrifuge like what they use
for blood to separate the platelets from
the from the plasma from all of this you
generally you don't stick the test tube
on one side you need a balancing test
tube so that it can rotate smoothly okay
so that's just to get the physics
balanced yeah and so so then why not
cycling your washing machine
I forgot all about that yeah yeah the
washing machine is walking down the
street to catch the bus you didn't put
stuff in there it right properly
balanced right right right
foreign
[Laughter]
yeah some washing machines they're
totally ready to walk out the door
exactly right so
uh all right so uh the point is
uh the higher the scenic fuse the more
effective this will be and the faster it
will take place okay
and the longer is your radius
Okay add a given speed the longer your
radius the better the better the
centrifuge so the centrifuge is enhanced
by how fast you're turning and how long
your your radius is from the center of
rotation okay okay so uh so there it is
and now why am I even mentioning this
yes we use the centrifuge
during the Manhattan Project
because uranium 238
has very different fission properties
from uranium-235
and so there's uranium ore
underground and we want to say some of
these atoms
have 238 nucleons and others have 235
and they're mixed together
right and you know we can't have that
pay my taxes not to have no 238 and 235
mixing up in my tank
foreign
take that to the Supreme Court that's
right
okay now all I'm saying is ain't nothing
wrong with 235 and ain't nothing wrong
with 238 they just need to be separate
but equal
can I finish
all right
now you can match it like
there's not much of a mass difference
between these two atoms right all right
one of them has like
three extra neutrons in it
compared to the other
all right so
if you melt the uranium so that atoms
can move freely because in a solid state
they can't right all right and you
centrifuge it
the 238 goes to the bottom and the 235
goes to the top okay
and what you can do is you know is it is
it going to do it perfectly uh maybe it
all doesn't go to the very bottom maybe
it only goes to the bottom half okay so
here's what you do you cut off the half
now you take the bottom half and
centrifuge that that's right
and then you take the bottom half of
that centrifuge that and you keep doing
this if you do it anymore we're gonna
have to put some sanctions on you
now we told you that you could do it for
him that's for energy purposes now you
keep on
putting that in that centrifuge we're
gonna destroy your economy okay so
that's why you have centrifuge when
you're creating nuclear physics Vision
all right so efficient bombs uh re
require one specific
size uranium atom and not the others and
so your centrifuge it and so that's why
if a country starts building centrifuges
and you might ask why oh we just like
centrifuge Why We Lost Planet stuff
s we love spinning
and so so there there you have it that's
a so centrifu centrifuges are very
important for a lot of industrial
applications just to separate out
liquids that otherwise
um
uh are fully mixed and there you have it
that is really cool actually yeah so a
spinning space station is basically a
centrifuge right and if you do it at 1G
you'll be okay but if you start
centrifuging at like 2G 3G like like the
if you're in a jet fighter and they do
like a a barrel roll or something and so
I'm experiencing Four G's five G's
they're basically centrifuging you right
yes it's like I feel my courage
separating from my butt I feel my pee
separated from my bladder
so yes you can broadly think of
increasing the g-forces on something as
the equivalent of putting it into
centrifuge it's precisely the same
effect on the thing that's in the thing
excellent now by the way I I went into a
centrifuge at Brandeis University a
little space research Zone there
and I uh I threw up afterwards
yeah so well you didn't do it during you
know no I did not not during because
that'd be bad because if you're if
you're in the centrifuge and you're like
facing the middle and you try to throw
up the throw-up goes back down your
throat that's awesome the centrifuge
pushes it back if so if you're ever in a
centrifuge and have to throw up turn
sideways oh yeah then the centrifuge
will go off to the side okay I actually
saw that happen not in anything as
illustrious as Brandeis University uh
but it was the University of Great
Adventure
were you a junior or senior when this
happened
and yeah it was like this it's this
thing you get into and you stick to the
walls as it spins around it'll spin
around and and I had a very light lunch
and I thought I was good so I so I would
count as the inadequate stuff instead of
the right stuff for a space exploration
there so um anyhow that's all we have
time for Chuck oh man okay that was fun
all right centrifuges and life that's
what that is all right that's Chuck nice
I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson keep looking up
foreign
[Music]